hey everyone this is steve launcher with
collider and uh i am thrilled to be with
everyone behind something you said last
night here in the toronto in our studio
at toronto um first of all
congratulations on being part of the
toronto film festival i i i'm so curious
what it means to you guys to be part of
this fest because for me it's my
favorite festival that i i love this
place and can you sort of talk about
what it means
yeah i mean
so for me the festival is uh it's kind
of a full circle moment for me
i used to actually work at the festival
as an usher ripping tickets sweeping
popcorn and yesterday when we premiered
our film that was the very theater i
used to clean
just a couple years ago so for me it
feels really good to be back with a film
i'm actually going to stop there for
this real quick because i realized
everyone watching this interview will
not have seen the movie yet or almost
everyone and i hate asking that generic
question but who wants to bite the
bullet and say how they've been
describing the film to friends and
family
uh yeah something you said last night
follows a woman on vacation with her
parents and teenage sister
and it's a story about family at the end
of the day and the woman is trans but
it's not the central
point of the story she's a sister she's
a daughter she's a granddaughter first
and she's trans second
one of the things that really struck me
about the film was the fact that it it's
a different kind of story than i
expected it's about a loving family a
very supportive family and i i was
waiting for the like and i don't want to
do any spoilers but i was waiting for
like a shoe to drop because that's what
i'm used to in these kinds of stories
and and instead it's just a really
loving supporting family and can you
sort of talk about that aspect in in for
all of you
anyone want to go i can take that yeah
i think it's such a beautiful story um
because it is such a rare story for
trans people to see
meeting louise i got to witness how her
family is so supportive of her and her
career
and that really changed my life and i
think it's going to be really awesome
for so many trans people to see this
kind of story
a story where being trans is not the
central
uh conflict within the family um so that
we can kind of
everyone can relate to this film uh
whether you're trans or not because we
all have a family
i'm so curious with the casting process
because
you've never been in a movie as far as i
know this is and you're in
i mean all the scenes you know so talk a
little bit about the casting process and
um let's just let me start with that
yeah so when it came to
renata who's the main character or
something you said last night um
we ran acting workshops rather than
doing the traditional audition
process just because i knew that most
likely it was going to be a girl who
didn't have a lot of acting experience
and the audition
that the typical audition format can be
quite overwhelming and quite abrasive i
think if you're not used to doing that
um
so we ran acting workshops that were
kind of like drama classes and i invited
different girls from the community to
come out and take them with us and we
had done a couple of those and i still
hadn't found like our girl yet
and then it's always a question of
everyone's always like how did you find
carmen but in the end it was kind of
like carmen found us
a friend of mine uh came home one day
and she was like i found the girl i know
this is your girl uh she walked into my
work and like you need to meet her and
then about a week later we met up i gave
her a scene to read without any context
and she knocked it out of the park like
i it was like magic watching her read
that scene with no context like i didn't
tell her about the story i didn't tell
her like what happens before the scene
after the scene she just knew
and
carmen has this quality of
um
intrinsically understanding the power of
silence which was really important to me
in casting this character she really
understands that uh
just because someone's not
speaking it doesn't mean they're not
saying anything ren says quite a lot in
her choice not to speak a lot of the
times and
carmen nailed that 100 percent and in
terms of miss paige over here
uh i think uh sienna
was one of the hardest characters to
cast just because we needed someone who
uh was quite bratty but also quite
likable and uh
i think you encompassed that very
well and also paige just like
you never
shirked at the idea of like getting ugly
or being silly
or doing all the ridiculous things i
made you do
like you were always like okay yes and
yes and come on improv
um
for my audition process i submitted my
tape thinking i butchered the audition
and i was like okay well i'm never gonna
hear from that again let's just continue
on
and then i got an email back then i got
another email back then i had a
chemistry read then i met with louise
and then
we went right into filming so for me it
was
wild because i thought i was never gonna
hear from that again
luckily i did
and playing sienna was so
fun and unique i had a difficult time
trying to figure out how i wanted to
play sienna because
she could be
bratty but you don't want people to only
think of somebody as a characteristic as
yourself you want to see them as a
person
so i wanted
to find the
simplicity and kindness and the sister
love within sienna and also the power in
silence and just listening and carmen
made it excellent just to act with we
just locked eyes and we connected and it
was wonderful one of the things that uh
i really enjoyed is that and it's hard
to do with film is making it sort of
feel like authentic and natural in the
moment where you're not watching
something scripted more like the cameras
the fly on the wall and you're just
watching these moments so can you sort
of talk about for all three of you like
pulling that off and when you felt like
you had it or you know what i mean being
authentic in the moment
for me um
coming into acting
i really always thought acting was
putting on these layers of a character
um i worked with a an amazing acting
coach vivian that louise introduced me
to
and um over the past year i've really
learned to just be a more authentic
version of myself with her learning how
to strip away these layers of characters
that we put on every day so that you can
really show up authentically and not
worry about how you're going to be seen
on the screen so for me
just having so much time to prepare and
do that work
to practice being more authentic in your
actual life as a trans person is a
really hard thing to do sometimes but
doing that made it a lot easier once we
got to sat to really allow that
authenticity and vulnerability to show
through a little bit
i also think it was amazing because we
did shoot on film so
you're limited with film you can't do
12 takes of a
five minute scene
so we rehearsed and rehearsed and
rehearsed and we went the weekend before
just the cast and we rehearsed every
scene we did
connections we we just bonded like that
so having the time to rehearse i felt
more confident going into it and i knew
that we could all do it because
we practiced because we had rehearsal
time it is it's so important to have
that first initial
spark with everybody and the connection
and i also think in modern day cinema
now there's a lot of
action movies and car crashes and
these crazy fight scenes and
great cool
but
i think the future of cinema is here
and
being able to just sit and watch
something that is so authentic and so
calm and beautiful and so much happening
within
so little
words
is
the most unique piece of cinema that
i've ever seen and i've ever been a part
of
that's the reason why i think so many of
us love movies or especially why i love
movies is the power to tell so many
different stories and diverse stories
and which leads me to a more serious
question i feel like the last few years
that there's been more representation
across the board um out of hollywood and
just in general but i'm curious how you
see it and if you agree with that or
what you'd like to say
yeah i mean i think this year at tiff
it's a stellar lineup for trans women in
particular we have h alberta alberto we
have uh vera drew we have our film and i
think the the dolls are really showing
up and showing out which is very
exciting that being said i still think
we have a lot of work to do um just
based off of like the conversations i
was having when i was talking to the
financiers for this project we had to
walk away with a from a lot of great
financiers just because they were asking
questions like well how do we know she's
trans and why don't we bring her
transness more to the front of the story
and why don't we make that more of like
a talking point in the film and and even
things like age they were like let's age
down ren because no one wants to see a
film about a 25 year old but but a film
about an 18 year old that's bankable
and and so i just feel like there's all
these different
layers of misogyny trans misogyny
um
and just like our preconceived notions
of like what a trans story is and we're
still
kind of
uh coming up against that wall
that being said all the financiers who
ultimately did sign on to this project
came on with just like a yes let's do it
no notes
let's go for it um so
i'd like to see more financiers like
that i think it makes the difference
um
and i think the dolls are having a
moment uh i'm very excited for trace
leset who just premiered monica in
venice uh so
we are we're making waves we are making
waves and i'm really proud of us
would you like to add anything
there's no pressure here i'm just
i'll just add that um
it has been amazing to work on set
because um
i think we get a lot of representation
in front of the camera when it comes to
trans women especially um
but it's still it's pretty rare to see
trans women being able to tell their own
stories the way that louise can
and she's just done an amazing effort at
bringing so many trans women on set
behind the camera in every department
really making sure that trans people
are given the opportunity so that they
can tell their stories i think that's
the next step representation is great
but when we can represent ourselves the
stories are so much more authentic and
people can connect with them even more
and i think that did help in the end
with your performance 100 because when
you woke up in the morning there was a
trans girl getting you dressed when you
sat in the makeup chair there was a
trans girl doing her makeup there was a
trans girl like working behind the
camera there was constantly a trans
presence on set in every single
department and i think it translates
yeah you i don't have to build up that
defense mechanism that you sometimes do
have to build up as a trans woman and so
that chosen the performance i think i
hope
uh i'm obsessed with talking about the
editing process because ultimately
that's where it all comes together so
i'm curious what you learned from any
friends and family screenings that
impacted the finished film
that's a good question
i think i learned that audiences are a
lot smarter than we give them credit for
um there was a lot more exposition i
think in my original
script and with every
uh pass
that we
made um after showing it to an audience
they were always like you can it was
just so clear of like what we could get
rid of
and i think it just both helped us
tighten
the the film and it also i think allows
for the audience to
be drawn in more because all of a sudden
what now they have to do is they have to
start filling in the blanks with their
own experiences
and i think it it
it allows for that experience that
cinematic experience that you want when
you go into the cinema of just being
able to like both see
someone else's life but also see your
life in them
um
so that's kind of what i learned in
terms of uh
showing the film
to audiences and friends and family and
yeah for all three of you i would
imagine the shoot you're looking at the
shooting schedule and what you have to
do each day and there must have been one
day on the shoot where you were like yet
it's circled like this is going to be a
tougher day you know i got emotionally
get ready or there's a lot of camera
stuff or whatever it may be so for each
of you what was that day on this shoot
that you had circled and were maybe a
little more nervous or excited
for me i was really nervous to film the
bathtub scene just because it's a very
vulnerable space for a human being to
strip down all the things that
hide myself like clothes and and
everything so whenever i could strip
that away and i was just in a bathtub
with carmen
that ended up being my favorite scene
that i've ever filmed in my life because
when you're in such a vulnerable state
and you have somebody else to like put
all of your energy there and to protect
you and make you feel safe like i i just
felt so
loved that day and i felt like it was so
special and how it turned out and i'm
just i'm so
proud of that scene but i was terrified
to do it the day but it's my favorite
scene
um there's a lot of those scenes that i
had to circle um
but
i'm gonna pick out um
the pool scene i think for me was a big
one
um
yeah i it's it's always nerve-wracking
um
again as a trans woman kind of exposing
yourself
um
and and in that scene you really see
something that a lot of trans women only
experience behind closed doors
so i was nervous about showing that to
the world and how i show that to the
world um but it was
um
i said yesterday at the screening it's
my favorite scene to watch i think now
i feel like i have an a and a b the a is
the island day that was like our longest
day by far
um just because we only had 19 days we
really had to like condense everything
and we only had one day to shoot all of
that
footage and it's quite a lot of uh
material to get through
so it was an 18-hour day and it was very
scary but we got through it the crew was
amazing i mean
um it was a very stressful shoot but not
once did they ever take out their stress
on the project or me it was kind of
something that we bonded over and there
was a lot of camaraderie on set and very
thankful uh for that group of people
and then the b to that
question
is uh something that i wasn't so worried
about and then the weather turned on us
like literally a couple hours before the
shoot um and it was our one overnight
shoot it's the scene where rand and
sienna go
to the parking lot with lonnie
and the scene was supposed to be a hot
sticky sweltering summer night and uh
obviously it's not that cause it's
pouring almost the entire scene and we
were not prepared for that
and uh it was a really uh
make it work moment but i think we made
it work and in the end like now i look
at that scene and i'm like oh that's
exactly how it had to be
shot there's something about the rain
that just adds this slick
um
i don't know like
scariness this this like dread almost
that our little indie budget would never
been able to reproduce
so that's one of the that's one of the
things that really struck me about the
film which is that like that scene as
i'm watching it i am like when's the
shoe dropping when like and then because
i've been
you know
movies have built me up to expect that
and that's one of the reasons why i
found your film so refreshing and just
i really enjoyed it because it just
tells a different kind of story um
anyway on that note i'm just gonna say
congratulations um on making
such a successful uh first feature and
uh thank you so much for coming in our
tiff studio and i hope that tiff is a
wonderful experience for all of you yeah
it's been good and thank you for such
lovely questions it was really nice
chatting i swear i've done this once
before and this is my second interview
i'm joking around listen um
i'm
thank you so much for coming in
you